an exciting virtual event a ux award for
ibm cloud satellite and ibm's inaugural
build a bot challenge all on this
episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
to start things off this week i'm
excited to invite you to our upcoming
virtual event cloud without compromise
this event is co-hosted by the wildly
talented comedian and musician reggie
watts and will be broadcast on september
23rd at 10 a.m
you'll hear the story of ibm cloud from
the lens of enterprise customers
startups partners and freelancers
they'll explain how and why they didn't
compromise in their cloud journey
the event promises to be action-packed
with interviews videos and demos
including demos for ibm cloud pack for
data as a service on ibm cloud satellite
and ibm cloud code engine
misconfigurations have been a major
cause of cyber security breaches and
ransomware attacks
we'll show a demo of a secure landing
zone where newly released apps can be
checked against pre-defined control
parameters and continuously monitored
after release
to register today and learn more about
this exciting virtual event check out
the link i've got in the description of
this video
next up i'd like to congratulate the ibm
cloud satellite and ibm design teams for
winning a red dot best of the best award
in the interface and user experience
design category
the red dot award is one of the most
competitive design awards in the design
industry in 2021 over 20 000 entries
from all over the world competed for the
awards
during the beta launch of satellite the
design team used ibm's enterprise design
thinking framework to map out the
customer journey and reduce time to
deployment
by using templates powered by ibm cloud
schematics they were able to reduce the
number of steps it takes to create a
satellite location from 90 to just seven
this means you can now create a
satellite location in as little as 15
minutes with just a few clicks
to learn more about ibm cloud satellite
and the ux design check out the link
i've got below
to wrap things up this week i want to
take a look at ibm's inaugural build a
bot challenge which featured some
groundbreaking robotic process
automation solutions
over 200 participants created rpa
solutions to improve the workplace and
the world and entered them into the
build a bot challenge
we crowned two winners and recently held
a webinar to celebrate the entries which
were each awarded a prize of ten
thousand dollars
for the best workplace improvement
solution category the winner was an rpa
bot to automate receipt submission and
expense reporting
in the rpa solution to address a social
challenge category the winner was an rpa
bot for virtual food bank program
to watch a replay of the webinar and get
to know more about the winning entries
hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud now